today I'm going to share my best career
advice for young people and its really
different than what you might hear from
others hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I really
got a great question for one of my
newsletter subscribers love you guys
Sneha I hope I pronounced that properly
who wrote in to say hey Evan I hope you
do read this mail and really hope you
can advise me Here I am let's go till
the time I graduated I just fixated on
being someone with a capital S it's
quite sad perhaps that I did not know
exactly what I wanted to be in life at
that time being just someone and
something big seemed important I
graduated in 2014 and got hired for
Deloitte the past five months I enjoyed
like I never had from being extremely
introverted I changed to being some
social I got confidence and also my job
demands networking it has all worked out
perfectly well until now I realized that
there is no more to life than one little
accomplishment so obvious that is I know
where I want to go I will admit I'm not
an entrepreneur type but I do not want
to expand my skill set I believe it can
be a good team leader not now but
someday there's a lot I have to work on
and I'm ready for those challenges I was
hoping you could tell me a few essential
things that I should not miss while
climbing up the ladder
how should I get the best out of my
company I'm not an extrovert so what
ways are there of networking are they
always about socializing with people on
personal level how do I learn most
effectively and improve my value in the
company I know there's a lot of
questions but please help me out I
really need your advice thanks a lot for
taking the timeliness email it means a
lot to me thanks and regards snow this
is a fantastic question and I think one
that a lot of young people face I think
every young person faces at some point
trying to figure out what you want to do
with your life and I think with every
big decision and I've talked about this
on the channel every big decision you
make is with the heart and not the head
right stop thinking so much and start
acting more now that's not saying be
totally reckless and go crazy you know
it's good to have a little bit of a gut
check there but too many people
overthink and as a result what happens
is you stay within the box that's what's
happening right corporate America is a
box and and I'm not saying you have to
be an entrepreneur it's totally cool you
don't be an entrepreneur something for
everybody but be an entrepreneur with
in the corporation what happens to so
many people is they get on a career path
and it's so well-defined for them right
you start off here you go here you go
here you go here you go here you'll be
here and gradually as you move up most
people become more and more and more and
more miserable right most people hate
their jobs and they're living for the
weekends and living for the the evenings
and they don't like their life right
they feel like they haven't become that
somebody with a capital S so the way to
do it and have success is to follow your
heart within the organization and
that'll mean stepping outside the box
that the corporation has defined for you
so you know your manager wants you to do
these five things well you know maybe
your colleague is working on a project
that really excites you go help them as
well maybe you've seen initiative that
you could be a leader on and help bring
to the company go work on that as well
and try to bring it don't ask for as
much permission still do the job you
know you're not getting in trouble from
your manager but look for other ways to
expand yourself and pull your heart and
passion to something even if it's
totally outside your current domain
because what most people follow is that
path of linear growth right you're
slowly moving up the ladder
we're really if you want to have massive
success and you want to be tremendously
happy in your life as well it's going to
look a lot Messier right if you don't
know where you want to go you don't know
quite where the top is going to be for
you it'll be really messy you're gonna
jump from here to here to here to here
to here to here to here and slowly
you're you'll move up you might move
down a little bit and then you'll take a
huge leap forward and that's normal
right that's fine that's okay but it's
not the safe thing that most people do
most people get locked in one thing and
that's where they are for the rest of
their careers look at something like
networking okay you hate networking I
ain't networking I'm not great at
networking I'm an introvert you may not
believe from the videos you know I can
get excited and get vocal I can yell the
videos but I am I am by nature and
introvert I don't talk to people on the
airplane I'm not talking to the guy next
to me I hate networking events with a
passion I don't know what to say I'm
clumsy I don't want to go up to summer's
day hi I'm Evan who are you what are you
all about some people are great at that
some people are like for the party
they really stand out they're amazing
That's not me it sounds like it's not
you so for you to think that you have to
have a networking skill to be effective
in your company that's living inside the
box and you're always going to be
restricted by that because it's not who
you are by nature so many people focus
on their weaknesses and what they're not
great at and trying to improve it
instead of focusing on what you're
really great at and being one of the
best in the world at that instead of
being a mediocre networker and slowly
moving your way up you could double down
on your strengths and do something that
you are so unbelievably amazing that to
build an amazing future for yourself so
for me again I hate networking the way I
flipped it was I'll only go to events
where I'm speaking right I've built
myself up as an authority in my industry
and now I'm speaking at events instead
of attending as a networker the only
other events I'll go to is where I'm
genuinely interested in learning from
the speaker or from the people who are
going to be there in which case I have
something in common right I'm not going
there just to hobnob with some of the
people and try to get to know them I'm
going there to actually better myself
and learn which gives me something to
potentially talk to people about so flip
it if you are not going to be the master
networker it's not you're in your DNA
it's not part of your personality it's
not a skill that's worth for you to
really double down on and maximize
because that's not who you are then
think about how can you flip that how
can you be the speaker at the next event
or how can you set up and be the creator
of the events and have people come to
you right create a system where people
want to come and talk to you instead of
you having to go out and talk to them
and that's just one example there are
probably countless of examples and
examples of examples of how you think
that this is the only way to succeed
because that's how corporate America
tells me to succeed and that's how
everybody in the company has succeeded
so far where you'll have a lot more
success if you are able to think outside
of that box break free
don't let them define who you are
because if you are living somebody
else's expectations of who you're going
to be you're never going to be the best
version of yourself
you're never going to come
the success that you can you're never
going to have the impact that you're you
would be able to have you're never going
to be that somebody with a capital S
because you're living somebody else's
expectations on you to be a great team
leader to be a great networker to be a
great fill in the blank and instead you
need to live your own version of your
life better on your strengths be the
best person in the world at what you do
and that brings tremendous value to your
company and gives you the best chance at
not only success but also happiness and
impact which I think are pretty
important so thank you very question and
continue to believe for those you're
watching I'd love to know what you think
I want a little bit of a rant and a tie
rate there let me know what you think
about how to have success in corporate
America leave a comment underneath I'd
love to see what you have to think and
of course if you like this video and you
want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and the
newsletter thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon